dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with doctor karoly jonahife
when watching science fiction movies we
often encounter
crazy devices and technologies that
don't really exist
or sometimes ones that are not even
possible to make
for instance reconstructing sound from
vibrations
would be an excellent example of that
and could make a great novel with the
secret service
trying to catch dangerous criminals
except that it has already been done
in real life research i think you can
imagine how surprised i was when i first
saw this paper
in 2014 that showcased a result where a
camera
looks at this bag of chips and from
these tiny tiny vibrations
it could reconstruct the sounds in the
room
let's listen mary had a little lamb
whose fleece was white as snow and
everywhere that mary went that lamb was
sure to go
yes this indeed sounds like science
fiction
but 2014 was a long long time ago
and since then we have a selection of
powerful learning algorithms
and the question is was the next idea
that sounded completely impossible
a few years ago which is now possible
well what about looking at silent
footage from a speaker
and trying to guess what they were
saying checkmark
that sounds absolutely impossible to me
yet this new technique is able to
produce the entirety of this speech
after looking at a video footage of the
leap movements
let's listen between the wavelength the
frequency and the speed of
electromagnetic radiation
in fact the product of the wavelength
and the frequency
is b wow
so the first question is of course what
was used as the training data
it used a data set with lecture videos
and chess commentary
from five speakers and make no mistake
it takes
a ton of data from these speakers about
20 hours from each
but it uses video that was shot in a
natural setting
which is something that we have in
abundance on youtube
and other places on the internet note
that the neural network
works on the same speakers it was
trained on and was able to learn their
gestures
and leap movements remarkably well
however
this is not the first work attempting to
do this so
let's see how it compares to the
competition
stay white with i7 soon
set white with i7 soon set white with i7
soon the new one is very close to the
true spoken sentence
let's look at another one elements
of function frame decision
eight field guns were captured in
position
note that there are gestures a
reasonable amount of head movement
and other factors at play and the
algorithm still
does amazingly well potential
applications of this
could be video conferencing in zones
where we have to be silent
giving a voice to people with the
inability to speak
due to aphonia or other conditions or
potentially fixing a piece of video
footage where parts of the speed signal
are corrupted
in these cases the gaps could be filled
with such a technique
look let's look at a cell potential of
0.5 volts for an oxidation of bromide
by permanganate the question i have is
what pkh would cause this voltage
would it be a ph now let's have a look
under the hood
if we visualize the activations within
this neural network
we see that it found out that it mainly
looks at the mouth
of the speaker that is of course not
surprising
however what is surprising is that the
other regions
for instance around the forehead and
eyebrows
are also important to the attention
mechanism perhaps
this could mean that it also looks at
the gestures of the speaker
and uses that information for the speech
synthesis
i find this aspect of the work very
intriguing
and would love to see some additional
analysis on that
there is so much more in the paper for
instance i mentioned
giving a voice to people with aphonia
which should not be possible
because we are training these neural
networks for a specific speaker
but with an additional speaker embedding
step it is possible to pair up
any speaker with any voice this is
another amazing work that makes me feel
like we are living
in a science fiction world i can only
imagine what we will be able to do with
this technique
two more papers down the line if you
have any ideas
feel free to speculate in the comment
section below what a time to be alive
this episode has been supported by snap
inc what you see here
is snap ml a framework that helps you
bring your own machine learning models
to snapchat's ar lenses you can build
augmented reality experiences
for snapchats hundreds of millions of
users and help them see the world
through a different lens you can also
apply to snap's ar creator residency
program with a proposal of how you would
use
lan studio for a creative project if
selected
you could receive a grant between one to
five thousand dollars
and work with snaps technical and
creative teams
to bring your ideas to life it doesn't
get any better than that
make sure to go to the link in the video
description and apply for the residency
program
and try snap ml today our thanks to snap
inc
for helping us make better videos for
you thanks for watching and for your
generous support and i'll see you
next time